ich faste mal ganz kurz zusammen weil es
eine menge war also überraschendes
statement paul ronzheimer ist noch bei
uns können wir gleich dazu holen laschet
hat als allererstes gesagt weil das
offenbar auch die voraussetzung war hier
ehrlichkeit walten zu lassen hat als
allererstes gesagt die cdu hat die wahl
nicht gewonnen wir sind auf platz zwei
eine relativ neue erkenntnis für armin
laschet die neue demut des armin laschet
man muss sagen auf den letzten metern
denn das ist das was er vielleicht
direkt am wahlabend zumindest am
nächsten tag hätte sagen müssen was das
zeichen gewesen wäre gerade wir können
doch noch mal drauf gehen das bild und
ton sind wieder da herrn habeck und frau
bullock ist das nächste gespräch jetzt
dann in ihrem präsidium bedeutet dass
sie auch nicht noch mal besonders mit
der fdp sprechen bevor es in die
nächsten gespräche zu dritt geht
wir sprechen jetzt mit unseren gremien
mit unserem sondierungsteam und alles
weitere werden wir dann in den nächsten
zeiträumen verkünden
herr otto
ferdinand otto von zeit online herr
laschet es oder vielleicht an sie
gerichtet wie groß schätzen sie den
schaden ein durch diese durchstechereien
die leaks und wurde da intern heute
vielleicht in der vorbesprechung auch
schon mal jemand rund gemacht und
angepfiffen
also ich habe auch etwas gelesen uhr das
gespräch zwischen der spd und den grünen
das ist nicht gut wenn es geschieht aber
wir haben uns heute
mehr mit der frage beschäftigt
wie kann man eigentlich diese
riesenaufgabe im moment vor uns liegen
lösen deshalb haben auch personalfragen
heute keine rolle gespielt ich finde die
müssen auch zurückstehen denn die
aufgabenstellung ist doch kann man das
was man vorhat was sie es ganz dringend
passieren muss
effizient durch bundestag und bundesrat
bringen mit einer breiten
gesellschaftlichen strömung das ist
unser angebot wir regieren in sehr
vielen ländern auch mit die waren mit am
tisch die ministerpräsidenten aus hessen
aus schleswig holstein auch aus dem
osten der noch mal einen besonderen
blick erfordert weil auch der kampf
gegen die afg und gegen rechts eine
gesellschaftspolitische aufgabe ist und
das hat heute die gespräche dominiert
weniger die frage was da wie
durchgesickert ist schön ist es nicht
aber die ernsthaftigkeit der lage vor
der deutschland steht war heute das
dominierende in unseren gesprächen
an vielen herzlichen dank für ihr kommen
danke für ihr interesse einen schönen
tag noch aktiv
haben und herne da sind wir wieder genau
wie tausend mal die bilder wir sind hier
groß im studio und die
pressekonferenz ist presse statement
dieses historische zwischen union und
den grünen ende mit bezug auf die handy
alarm bombe die hierbei bild geplatzte
seinen laschet wurde danach gefragt und
es war paul
du hast es geht um dein handy es war
schon interessant zu sehen als er einen
moment zögerte dann überlegte welche
antwort kann ich geben und dann statt zu
sagen ja mist dass das hier dass wir
hier nicht dicht gehalten haben
geht er auf die anderen sagt ich habe
auch etwas gelesen so das gespräch mit
der spd und dann fängt er an zu
schmuggeln und kommt wieder in
allgemeine ja fast wie wahlkampfprogramm
ausflüchte ami laschet hat da ganz klar
versucht die handy alarm bombe runter zu
spielen das ist mir aber nicht wirklich
gut gelungen denn er ist dann eher als
erst gesagt hat ich habe das auch
gelesen ist alles nicht gut aber hier
ging es um inhalte und deswegen haben
wir gar nicht darüber gesprochen fakt
ist die nachricht hat eben das alles
dominiert vorher wenn wir uns die
titelseiten der online-medien anschauen
wenn wir die süddeutsche zeitung
gesprochen über alle anderen medien alle
berichten darüber dass das
möglicherweise hier ein entscheidender
stoss hat sein können aber was hätte
anderes tun sollen also erst dann raus
gegangen und hat gesagt das hätte alles
keine rolle gespielt
und es ging jetzt nicht wenige es ging
weniger um die frage was durchgesickert
sei der sich das land ja es geht um
deutschland genau ich fast noch mal ganz
kurz zusammen ich glaube der eindruck
ist nicht fall schon jetzt hat jedes
zitat einzugehen der eindruck ist nicht
falsch dass die cdu sowohl armin laschet
als auch csu-chef söder sich da
öffentlich den grünen wirklich an den
hals geschmissen haben sie haben gesagt
glaube das wäre möglich hätte eine hohe
akzeptanz in der gesellschaft die union
ist bereit zu jamaika es war ein guter
austausch wir haben gedanklich an 2017
angeknüpft die ersten jamaika gespräche
das sagte laschet söder sagte
konstruktiv aber auch sehr ehrlich
immerhin viele gemeinsamkeiten und wenn
alle guten willens seien dann gäbe es
auch chancen diese gespräche
fortzusetzen das war auch mein eindruck
die union ist offen dafür was sollten
sie auch andere seien am ende verlangen
diejenigen die sie gewählt haben dass
die regierungsverantwortung versuchen zu
übernehmen am spannendsten fand ich die
sätze von annalena baerbock denn sie hat
darüber gesprochen über besondere
verantwortung über verlässlichkeit
verantwortung und trauen sie hat es
nicht angesprochen direkt die handy
alarm bombe aber sie hat es gemeint und
ist ja dafür gewesen zwei erster sein
ist aber darauf hingewiesen dass
sozusagen in den anderen gesprächen das
alles gewahrt geblieben sei also ein
erster hand kann man sagen in richtung
union wenn es denn platz das ist
möglicherweise daran
liegen könnte und wenn man weiter geht
muss man sagen es gab sozusagen in der
frage was jetzt passiert auch eindeutige
aussagen begrünen die gehen jetzt in
ihre teams in ihre sondierungsteams und
dann in die parteigremien und wenn man
über die parteigremien der grünen
spricht dann muss man sagen da kann eine
menge gerade in den vergangenen stunden
in den vergangenen tagen gegen die union
ich hab ja auch ein paar thematische
sachen die auch angesprochen wurden
thema migration klima da gibt es
differenzen wo siehst du die größten
hürden die die beiden parteien nehmen
müssten die größte hürde sehe ich für
die grünen darin dass ihre basis auf rot
grün und dann sozusagen auf ampel zählt
dass man immer wieder hört dass bei der
grünen-basis ganz unabhängig von der
thematischen festlegung eben die
vorliebe ist für eine ampel und dann die
zweite hürde tatsächlich das was jetzt
in den vergangenen stunden seit gestern
seitdem wir darüber berichtet haben was
dort passiert ist dass dort eine neue
dynamik entstanden ist bei den grünen in
die richtung mit dieser union mit dem
chaos das geht doch nicht das heißt wenn
man sich jetzt noch mal um 180 grad
drehen würde und dann sagen würde okay
wir versuchen jetzt doch jamaika da
fehlt ein bisschen die basis und da geht
es nicht so sehr um die frage gibt es da
probleme beim migration gibt es probleme
bei steuern und so weiter das werden
erst die themen die danach hoch kommen
würden also in wirklichen
koalitionsverhandlungen momentan geht es
um das öffentliche bild das die union
momentan abgibt wir haben über die handy
alarm bombe gesprochen aber eben auch
wie sich die partei insgesamt zeigt wie
sparen wie märz wie alle wie röttgen
dort auf armin laschet zugegangen sind
für die grünen ist es schwer ihre
parteibasis zu erklären warum man mit
jemandem der die wahl verloren hat und
so tief sozusagen gefallen ist überhaupt
zusammenarbeiten soll trotzdem paul muss
man sagen die sowohl habe ich als auch
annalena baerbock haben es ja sehr
geschickt gemacht um sich nicht selber
hier als totalverweigerer
hinzustellen nach dem hinweis wörtlich
zur verantwortung gehört verlässlichkeit
und vertrauen kam aber auch das war ein
sehr konstruktive und sachliche und
ernsthafte gesprächen differenzen ja
aber auch gemeinsame schnittmengen von
ernsthaftigkeit geprägt gewesen und habe
sagte es gab schnittmengen aber auch
trennendes und es sei ein intensives
gespräch gewesen also sie haben sich
natürlich selber ganz gut dargestellt
wir sind hier nicht totalverweigerer
sondern natürlich sind wir offen müssen
das aber wirklich nicht tun alles was da
von den grünen kommt ist pure taktik
denn man darf ja eine sache nicht
vergessen wenn sie jetzt in
verhandlungen mit der spd gehen brauchen
sie ja das fenster ihre
verhandlungsmasse um sagen zu können na
ja also ganz mit den mit der union
aufgegeben haben wir es nicht also olaf
scholz muss bei den kommenden
verhandlungen wenn es dazu kommen sollte
zu den ampel immer im kopf haben um
gottes willen die grünen und die fdp
haben es in der hand die können
scheitern lassen wenn ich nicht genug
für klimatour aus unions grünen sich bei
der migration mich anders positionieren
und all diesen themen dh die aussagen
jetzt in so einer pressekonferenz werden
natürlich auch in diesem moment von olaf
scholz ganz genau angeschaut und der
soll nicht sicher sein dass die grünen
und die fdp
absolut sicherer partner für eine ampel
[Musik]